[Music]
i have to ask you about face-off
i get i guess first how exactly did you
wind up getting cast in that movie
i got cast in the film face-off because
of john woo
who is a hero of mine and he directed
that it was the second american feature
after broken arrow
and um he was so incredible and
i had been friends with chao young fat
who is the star of many of his hong kong
films in an iconic
chinese actor and um so
them along with michelle yeoh and i were
in san francisco together doing a big
event
for um asian actors asian
storytelling this is in the 90s and so i
was really lucky to
get to be involved in face off and what
a big production i
i know that the film actually it takes
place
over a week but it took us almost a year
to shoot
it was um many many many stunts
they actually explode a plane and they
really did this is like
90s action filmmaking where
they could they could actually explode a
plane without cgi this is before
so many of these things were created
with cgi we had none of that we only had
planes and explosives and um you know
there was a lot of
going to um training camps
where you would learn how to properly
shoot a gun
properly uh look like you were
in the fbi and um john wu had a lot of
input on making sure that actors were
comfortable
with how they were physically portraying
these characters you also had a stunt
double that was the
pretty much the physical
perfection version of yourself which is
really strange
so i had um a stent devil and i think
john travolta has like
had like five or six of them as did
nicolas cage
uh but we all had either one or more
people who were our stunt devils who
were doing the stunts and were just
um ourselves but perfect versions which
is really funny
all those resources pay off big time i
feel like you don't
get that that kind of classic uh 90s
action style and
as much as i am wowed by vfx artists
it's just
it's not quite the same it's not that
reach out and touch it kind of feel
well there's a really um it's a really
interesting way of making movies
where everything is so
real and so true and when there's
um explosives there's explosions i mean
that's just a very
interesting thing that i had not really
seen or been a part of so i was excited
to be there
how about working with john travolta in
particular
were there any expectations going into
working with him and did he surprise you
in any way
well john travolta is just like a modern
day
king in that there's not really
american monarchy but there is in
hollywood if you think about it and
he's sort of in the last era of the
golden age of hollywood he's sort of the
last
movie star in a lot of ways and so he
had this sort of like
court around him of different people
that he had worked with his particular
crew whether they were his stand-ins or
his
his um you know stunt doubles or his uh
crew that he would bring from movie to
movie so you would
see like sort of the skeletal like
remnants of different films he had done
over the years and
so that was really interesting and he
was a really jovial guy
really fun we had um lunch one time
in his trailer he and i and he ate
an entire nine inch boysenberry pie
with a fork no plates no knives
i i feel like i maybe i shouldn't be
impressed but i am
is well it was after a beef wellington
also
lots of pastry
you